well a group of election officials
targeted by former president trump after
the 2020 election had some harrowing
stories to tell on capitol hill
yesterday at a hearing of the january 6
committee republican office holders and
a poll worker in georgia described death
threats and other forms of harassment
from trump supporters all because the
former president was lying about them
scott mcfarlane is on capitol hill for
us scott some scary stuff
yeah tony emotional compelling testimony
from these local election officials who
say despite being targeted by donald
trump they stood their ground
and paid a price
in the chaotic days after the 2020
election
and weeks before the january sixth riot
arizona's state house speaker republican
rusty bowers testified he stood up to
trump and his legal team's repeated
attempts to overturn the election
results you were asking me to do
something against my oath and i will not
break my oath bowers says former trump
attorney rudy giuliani was relentless
claiming he had evidence of election
fraud but never producing any he said
we've got lots of theories we just don't
have the evidence bower's resistance has
come at an enormous personal cost to him
and his family we have
various groups come by
and
they have had
um
video panel trucks with videos of me
proclaiming me to be a pedophile and a
pervert the stories of harassment and
pressure were echoed in georgia why
wouldn't you want to find the right
answer brad instead of keep saying that
the numbers are right where trump and
his lawyers ask the state's officials to
decertify their electors and investigate
baseless claims of fraud we just
followed the law we followed the
constitution
and at the end of the day president
trump came up short the committee also
revealed text messages between a
stafford and wisconsin senator ron
johnson and a top aide to then vice
president mike pence suggesting the
senator wanted to deliver a slate of
fake electors defense on the senate
floor january 6 but was told not to a
spokesperson for johnson denied the
claim i was not involved in this at all
some of the most emotional testimony of
the day came from georgia election
worker shay moss who said she and her
mother have experienced harassment after
trump falsely accused them of bringing
in fake ballots i don't want to go
anywhere i second guess
everything that i do
it's affecting my life in a major way
in every way all because of lies
for me doing my job
her mother ruby friedman testified that
there's nowhere they feel safe now
do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you
the president of the united states is
supposed to represent every american
not to target one
the hearings resume tomorrow the
committee says with a focus on the 11th
hour interference by donald trump on the
u.s justice department nate
scott thank you